we're leaving you with some good vibes
to get you through the rest of your
monday or you can watch that if you want
and today it's courtesy of chris brad
and catherine schwarzenegger yeah the
a-list couple recently took part in the
new season of netflix's get organized
with the home edit and in the new clip
fans got a rare look at chris and
catherine's life together as they saw
their reorganized garage for the very
first time bye everyone
all right here we go
so excited you ready
oh
this is insane
look at you have a nice little work
space i sure do
i'm so excited about everything the
colors are so beautiful the labels and
just like how clean and beautiful
everything looks what made me so excited
is looking at that little workbench i
know exactly what my first project i'm
going to do on that workbench and i'm
excited about it chris i want you to
open your drawers yeah here we go and
you have a workstation
yes these are just they're just
christmas yeah
yeah let's get to work